mic Bresnahan he's the Lakers analyst
for spectrum Sports Net Mike Ross Tucker
filling in for Dan today here on the Dan
Patrick show a bunch of LeBron Lakers
questions for you that I've been curious
about and the first one is really simple
Mike which is just how does LA feel
about LeBron right now like if you
walked around the arena or you taught
walk down the street
how do people out of people feel about
LeBron in LA right now good question
boss Ross and I'll tell ya there was a
nice ovation form just the other night
when he passed MJ to move into fourth on
the NBA's all-time scoring list but
there's no doubt about it there is
definitely some empty feelings about the
Lakers as a team right now I mean it is
just you know you go back to last July
there is so much euphoria there is so
much hope when LeBron signed with the
Lakers and the fact that they're what
five games under 500 you know it feels
like everyone every Laker fan is upset
it's just about every every part of the
franchise right now some people say
LeBron needs to you know step up a
little bit more some people say the
coaching staff is an issue some people
say the front office is an issue and
there's just a lot of things are
pointing going on right now and and you
never ever would have predicted it last
July just what you know six seven eight
short months ago it's surprising to be
honest this is probably more a fan
question or even for the day Annette's
or for me to chime in on but I am
curious do you think as a basketball guy
do you think this season and the Lakers
not making the playoffs do you think
that that has a negative effect or
impact at all on LeBrons legacy no it's
too soon if it was a one year deal for
him then yeah you probably say wow that
didn't work out well but the Lakers
signed him to a four-year contract so
you have to see what they can do this
this offseason
try to upgrade the roster because there
were definitely some holes in this
roster back when the season began way
back when in October and no one thought
this team was going to be a championship
caliber but that people definitely
figure
all right they should probably be top
four in the West and do some pretty good
damage there if the young guys step up
their game a little bit and some of the
many guys that were on one-year
contracts maybe they could do something
to to kind of get a little a little
action a little playoff action for a
franchise that has not been the playoffs
since 2013 and it just hasn't happened
part of it was LeBron was was he missed
18 games because of a groin injury and
that's that's rough and that's the
longest injury he's ever had in his
career and there's been other problems
too you know long the ball has not
played since January Brandon Ingram
missed a little time so it's been
definitely injury filled season so I
think that kind of stems some of the
harshest criticism rightly so because no
one predicted so many guys would miss so
much time I guess I'm just curious what
the reaction was to his thoughts and
comments that you know beating Michael
Jordan and going ahead of him on the
all-time scoring list was like winning a
title how'd that go over in LA you know
here's the funny thing
LA people they're very Lakers centered
and they're smart NBA fans but they're
not that attuned to maybe the Miami OKC
series at LeBron won in 2012 or 13 or
whatever year it was yeah I can't even
name the specifics of him winning that
championship so so for him to say yeah
this is cooler than when when we beat
Golden State three years ago or whatever
the timeframe was for that
I think Laker fans kind of shrugged that
off because they're waiting for him to
win one year and that's the important
theme yeah this franchise has not wanted
Santa since since 2010 it granted then
did went back-to-back oh nine and ten
with Kobe and one of those years they
beat Boston so there's definitely a lot
of bang for that [ __ ] but but it wasn't
if you feel like here to be honest
talking with Mike Bresnahan does a
terrific job as the Lakers analyst for
spectrum Sports Net a lot of Lakers
LeBron talked this week and the latest
Mike is that they
are going to limit his minutes you know
Luke Walton has already said that for
the rest of the season what's your read
on how much they're going to limit his
minutes and why yeah I can't wait for a
practice this morning when Luke Walton
will be asked that question for sure
probably by me well to see what happens
in a few hours
I would guess he's gonna do about 25
minutes game it's about 10 fewer and he
has been playing on average maybe even
20 minutes again
and now it's no longer a let's push for
the playoffs now it's kind of a rescue
mode where it's like alright let's look
ahead to the next season we still have
LeBron this is what the Lakers are
thinking for three more years after this
so yeah we've got to kind of conserve
him a little bit he's 34 years old now
he'll be 35 in December that's quite a
ways away obviously but he definitely
need to turn to what can we do to
preserve him obviously a lot of miles on
him he's played what an extra two
seasons at least just in playoff games
over the years so it makes sense to me
in fact I even said to my co-workers a
couple of nights ago at the Lakers loss
and the Clippers you know I think I
start kerbin him a little bit maybe sit
him in certain games and indeed one of
the reports said he's also going to set
out something back-to-back situations of
which the Lakers have three remaining
between now in April 9th the last
regular season game so it makes sense to
me the kind of preserve him a little bit
since they've fallen very quickly and
very far out of the playoff race okay
but by that logic Mike why don't they
just shut him down for the rest of the
year you know what why put any more
minutes on them why take any risk of
injury that's a great question and maybe
LeBron is the guy who's saying I feel
like I need to play some here and give
the fans what they want maybe it's the
Lakers saying you know we need to kind
of show our season ticket holders are
loyal season ticket holders that yeah
you know they're part of the process too
I'm not sure a which on which side the
minister striction was was agreed upon
as far as hey there needs to be some
playing time here Bunker's see what what
is determine a practice today probably
is some sort of agreement between both
sides that yeah
let's not shut it down completely let's
at least give the fans 2025 minutes
whatever the number might be is there
any chance Mike that part of this is a
way for the Lakers to lose even more
games to finish the season to get you
know more ping-pong balls and even if
they don't get in in the top three to at
least get a higher pick is there a a
partial tank here going on the problem
with that is they have too many wins
they have so many wins that even if they
lose they have I believe 17 games left
even if they lose 14 of them they're not
going to prove their position that much
you go from maybe a 1% chance to get in
the top pick - a 4% chance to get in the
top pick so I don't really see that
happening just because the percentages
aren't that great Mike really appreciate
the time thank you so much for coming on
the show there is Mike Bresnahan check
him out all over spectrum Sports Net he
is the Lakers analyst and he called me
boss Ross so I already liked that guy
quite a bit for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show at
[Music]